Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain a Japanese youth comedy drama film
called “Flying Colors”. Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Sayaka Kudo is in middle school but has no
friends. She is socially anxious and often
bullied by her classmates. She has two younger
siblings; brother Ryuta and sister Mayumi. Her
father only focuses on Ryuta who he thinks will
one day become a baseball superstar. The sisters
are often left alone with their mother who takes
great care of them. All of Sayaka’s classmates
have a dream in life. She, however, wants to do
nothing. Because of her lack of ambition, she is
not good at studies either. One day, Sayaka gets
hit on her head with a ball in the playground.
Her mother is called by the principal and told
that they cannot teach someone like Sayaka
in the school. The teachers think she is suffering
from some kind of mental illness and needs to go
to a special school. Sayaka’s mother begs them to
give her daughter a second chance but her words
go to waste as the principal dismisses her.
While returning home, Sayaka sees two schoolgirls
walk past them. She comments that their uniform is
pretty and hence is admitted to the same school.
Sayaka is nervous on her first day of school,
scared that the new classmates will bully her
like the old ones. But to her surprise, everyone
is nice to her, especially a group of three girls
who befriend her instantly. They make her fold her
skirt to make it shorter so it would look better.
They also do her makeup and hair in the
washroom and welcome her to their group.
As the girls grow up, they transform into
gyaru, a person who follows western traditions,
typically dyes their hair blonde, and wears
revealing clothes. They frequently dress up,
party, drink, and smoke, completely disregarding
their studies. Their homeroom teacher Mr.
Nishimura scolds them every day and believes
that they will certainly not get into college.
Most days, Sayaka returns home in the morning when
her father and brother are exercising outside the
house. The relationship between her and her
father has become non-existent with time. He
only talks to her when he has to scold her while
she ignores him entirely. Her mother, however,
is always on her side and supports her, even
though she doesn’t understand her lifestyle.
Sayaka’s life changes on the first day of
sophomore year. That is when Mr. Nishimura
discovers a hidden packet of cigarettes in
her school bag. She is immediately sent to
the principal’s office to face the repercussions
of her action. Her mother is called and briefed
about all of Sayaka’s shenanigans. She begs
the principal to let her daughter stay,
arguing that the school’s job is to teach its
weakest students, not profit off the smartest
ones. On her repeated request, they agree to
let Sayaka off with a month of suspension.
Since Sayaka has all the time in her hands, she
dyes her hair blond. Her mother suggests she try
to get into a university. She genuinely believes
that if Sayaka tries, she can do it. To prepare
her for her university entrance examination,
Ms. Kudo sends her to Seiho Cram School.
The teacher Tsubota is shocked to see someone
like Sayaka interested in being tutored by him.
He motivates her and takes on the challenge to
help her enter Keio University. It is considered
one of the most prestigious and difficult to enter
universities in Japan which makes Sayaka laugh at
the thought that someone like her can be selected.
To check the level of her academics, Tsubota
makes her take a test. Sayaka scores zero out of
hundred but the teacher is still impressed because
she answered all the questions, when any other
student would have given up at that point.
After evaluating her academics, he declares
that her knowledge is comparable to a grade four
student. Hence, he starts from the beginning,
teaching her the syllabus from middle school.
The next day, Sayaka goes to a restaurant
with her friends but studies the entire time.
The girls are shocked and happy at the same
time that she is working hard for something.
After studying in the cram school for a week, she
scores five out of hundred for the first time.
Tsubota is happy about the result and
urges her to work even harder. He is a
great teacher to all of his students. He never
makes them feel dumb for not knowing something
and does his best to keep their spirit
up. However, with Sayaka, he struggles a
lot because she doesn’t even know simple things
like the north is always opposite to the south.
Sayaka’s father refuses to pay for her cram class
because it is too expensive. Moreover, he doesn’t
believe that she can ever get into a university.
Her mother, on the other hand, is determined to
work harder and pay for Sayaka’s tuition.
One day while Sayaka is studying in the cram
school, a mother drags her son Reiji inside. He
is also a gyaru like Sayaka and is uninterested
in studying. Reiji’s parents are lawyers
and want him to take the same profession
but he is only interested in playing video games.
Tsubota asks him if he knows what revenge play is.
This piques Reiji’s interest and he starts
to study hard to get into law school and
teach his father a lesson. As days pass by, Sayaka
makes significant progress but Tsubota wants to
accelerate it. Hence, he finds an interesting
way to teach her. He makes her take off a
layer of makeup for every wrong answer. He even
promises to show the students an embarrassing
picture from his childhood when Sayaka scores
a hundred in middle school’s English test.
Starting that day, Sayaka studies all the time
and eventually gets a perfect score on the test.
As promised, Tsubota shows them a picture from
his childhood and tells him how he was an average
student which is why he wants to help them.
Following that, Sayaka dyes her hair black and
continues going back to school. When Mr. Nishimura
finds out she is aiming to go to a university,
he jokes about dancing naked in the
school’s playground if she succeeds.
Sayaka challenges him and is even more motivated
after the incident. One day, Sayaka and Reiji are
outside a restaurant when they see Tsubota meeting
Mr. Nishimura. It turns out that Mr. Nishimura is
also funding the cram classes and doesn’t want
Tsubota to take in weak students like Sayaka.
He thinks the class’s reputation is more important
than the student’s future. Tsubota argues that he
has faith in Sayaka and knows that she will get
into her desired university. Seeing a father
figure stand up for her, Sayaka gets teary.
At home, Ms. Kudo notices that her daughter has
grown into a better person since she started to
go to cram classes. The next day, she is called
by Tsubota to discuss Sakaya’s progress. He
claims that Sayaka is the fastest learning
student he has had but since they do not have much
time before the university entrance examination,
she needs to come to cram class six days a week.
This will cost her a lot of money but she pays the
school after taking a loan from her relatives.
Sayaka finds out about this from Tsubota
and is saddened that she is causing her mother so
much trouble. One day, her friends invite her to
a restaurant. Sayaka goes but is busy studying
the entire time. The girls then take her to the
hot spring and claim that they will only hang
out again after Sayaka’s exams because they know
how hard she is studying for it. Sayaka cries
and thanks them for being understanding.
A few months later, Sayaka finally upgrades
to the high school syllabus book and has to
study how to write an essay. Tsubota gives her
several books and asks her to watch a lot of news.
When the syllabus gets tougher, she has a hard
time focusing. She even cuts her hair short to
show her resolve. Over the weeks, she studies
so hard that she dozes off during most of her
classes at school. One day, Mr. Nishimura
wakes her up by grabbing her by her hair.
He calls her mother to tell her that her
daughter hasn’t improved since she was
suspended. But Ms. Kudo retaliates that Sayaka
is not the girl she was a few months ago.
The next day at Cram class, Reiji comes in with
dark hair, glasses, and a completely changed look.
On being asked, he says that Sayaka inspired him
to work harder. Following that, Sayaka takes her
first mock entrance exam. When the results are
published, she is disappointed to have gotten
only sixty out of a hundred when the minimum score
to get into her desired university is seventy.
Tsubota thinks it is incredible because only some
months ago, she would have scored zero. But Sayaka
is disappointed that all that hard work is still
not enough. She returns home to see her father
manhandling her brother Ryuta for saying that he
doesn’t want to play baseball anymore. Ryuta snaps
and pushes his father away, shouting that he never
wanted to play baseball in the first place. He
storms off and doesn’t return home that night.
The following day, Sayaka takes yet another mock
exam but doesn’t score enough. The stress and
sleep deprivation catches up to her and she loses
motivation to study. Tsubota tries to motivate
her but his optimism makes her even more furious.
She lashes out at him and runs away from the Cram
class. She doesn’t come out of her room for the
next two days. Then, one night, Ryuta returns
home and informs his father that he has left the
school’s baseball team. Ever since Mr. Kudo had to
give up his dream of being a baseball player, he
had dreamt of making his son the greatest player
of all time. Seeing his dreams crash once again,
he hits Ryuta, asking him to come back to his
senses. Ms. Kudo gets so frustrated that she
breaks a vehicle’s window to stop her husband.
When he is distracted, Ryuta takes the opportunity
to run away from home again. Ms. Kudo tells
them about a time Ryuta had an asthma attack
the night before a match because he was scared
he would be scolded if he didn’t perform well.
She belittles her husband for being an
awful father to all of his children.
Later, Sayaka asks her mother to accompany her
on a field trip to Keio University. They visit
the university grounds the next day and are amazed
by it. Ms. Kudo wishes that her daughter will have
the same lifestyle as the busy students walking
down the hallways. At night, Sayaka goes to cram
class and meets Tsubota. She apologizes for being
rude and thanks him for being patient with her.
She also promises to continue the classes from
the next day. A week later, Sayaka takes her
third mock exam but is too scared to look at the
results. On coming back home, she finds her father
burning all the baseball kits that he bought for
Ryuta. He has realized his mistake and wants to
be a better father from now onwards. He promises
to support his children with whatever they want
to do in life. As the family shares an emotional
moment, Sayaka shows them the recent mock exam
results where she has scored sixty-five.
Her parents are prouder than they have
ever been. Cut to the day of the entrance
examination. The roads are blocked because
of heavy snowfall and the bus route is closed.
Sayaka’s father offers to drive her which is
surprising because he has never been involved
in her life in the slightest way. On their way,
he asks her to do her best and not worry about
the tuition fee because he has it managed.
After dropping her off, he even cheers for his
daughter for the first time in his life.
Sayaka does her best in the test and returns
home. Later that day, she goes to the cram class,
declaring that it is her last day. She doesn’t
want to return to tell him the results,
scared that she will disappoint him. She also
makes Tsubota sign her dictionary so he would
always be there when she studies. Before leaving,
she hands him a letter, thanking him for believing
in her and making her who she is today.
A few days later, she checks the result on
the internet, only to find that she didn’t pass.
She calls Tsubota and tells him about the result.
Tsubotat doesn’t give up and insists that they
can appeal for her answer sheet to be rechecked
under faculty policies. Sayaka gives up and
doesn’t apply for it, so Tsubota does it for her.
For the next few days, she goes out with
her friends every day, trying to live her
old lifestyle but no matter what she does, she
cannot help but feel disappointed. Then, one day,
she checks the results again, and to her surprise,
sees that she has gotten into Keio University.
She immediately cycles to the cram class
and is out of breath when she meets Tsubota.
When she tells him she has been accepted, the
entire class erupts into cheers. Both Tsubota and
Sayaka can’t help but bawl their eyes out. In the
last montage, we see Mr. Nishimura naked on the
school grounds, taking pictures with the girls
as he had promised. Sayaka leaves for college
after wishing her parents farewell.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.